[Music]
and i think i had been concerned as
early as march 2020
that there were
i'd say generally under appreciated
risks associated with attending even
medium to small events
cases were spreading it was hard to
figure out how many cases there really
were through all these questions of
whether or not the case were being
documented and we're fairly certain they
were under ascertained underdocumented
and we wanted to translate that in some
way
to communicate that out
to the world so one of the big things
that we focus on
is creating
like interactive interfaces around not
just like bioinformatics tools but also
say public health related things
and our shine is really a great tool for
this i put out a tweet which tried to
highlight this relationship between
how big an event was how many people
might be infected where there was
uncertainty and highlighting the risk
that one or more individuals in a group
of that size at that moment might be
infected leading to obviously potential
risk for spread
this went in its own way viral
and spread very rapidly i think people
started to realize that this was a
compelling communication tool think
about who your audience is going to be
um absolutely
and don't don't think about like oh i
would find this cool so other people
would find it cool too so we had to take
all of those different
individual data sets and
some of those listed cumulative cases
some of them listed daily cases and we
had to make sure that was all formatted
correctly the balancing between how
straight the straightforwardness of our
app
and the the number of information or
selectable variables in our app was one
of the most discussed topic in our
discussions i think we just want to
focus
what is the most important things and to
present information for the users we
don't need something like very big very
fancy but like something very essential
i mean theoretically it would be better
if we have more options
but we need to limit that number of
options to make the speed or
the usability of the app good enough
so i think we ended up having keeping
only two user variables
one was the size
of the events and one other was the
certain bias which can vary across the
different locales
we originally were thinking
about
data
applied to georgia as the state
and
at that same kind of time this
mapping project was taking off we
launched a state level thing in may
without the visualization
and it's really the visualization that
we work so hard on with cleo and solha
that when that was released
in that day it was very clear i had some
expectation it would spread but this was
it went much faster that's in part
because it started to spread on facebook
and twitter and instagram and started to
go through social media sites and that
really was this kind of stepping stone
into this project
where we
then
applied that concept to other countries
in europe
this particular metric i think is
something that people can really
get grips on and understand a lot more
easily than some of the other ones like
cases per hundred thousand people i mean
i don't even know
uh
a
bigger group a hundred thousand people
how much space they would take up but
it's very hard to visualize and think
about communicate risk at a personal
level right that people get what it
means to be at a restaurant with 50
people they're not sure what to always
do
with a positivity rate or case rates
that are cumulative because that's not
necessarily the relevant risk of pedal
making sure that as developers you have
a question in mind
and i think that requires taking a bit
of an empathetic perspective
with respect to your potential users it
wasn't meant to be complicated was meant
to be accessible and trying to take
simple quantitative principles in the
midst of pandemic and letting them
be utilized in this really this kind of
public accessible form
you